i am speaking today with a an american
soccer player who has
traveled the world or not the world but
certainly spent a lot of time in europe
playing soccer football as they call it
there and has learned a lot of languages
and has a
quite a presence on the internet so i
will ask will john to perhaps well john
good evening in sweden can you introduce
yourself
yeah sure uh on i will i will even come
on as my first statement and correct you
i have traveled the world thanks to
football so yeah it's taken me
everywhere not just europe but uh so
yeah i'm from kansas city i i grew up
there my father's
he is from nigeria my mom was from
chicago and uh yeah i played in the mls
which is the the highest league over in
in the us
and then since there i've played more or
less
12 13 years
outside
in europe so i played in denmark in
finland in croatia serbia i played in
morocco for a season which was wow wild
fun uh and uh and in baku as as well wow
so baku is azerbaijan for people who
don't know that's right so so with that
how many languages do you speak
so i am
always i guess you could say in the
process of learning new stuff but i'm
comfortable to say that i'm quite
conversationally fluent in eight at the
moment okay and uh at 16 my idea was to
learn 10.
uh and it was because i i read the book
the kind of monte
fell in love with the story of a guy who
was able to travel the world learn all
these
these neat things uh the whole world was
his friend everyone was his friend and
all the doors were open to him and that
kind of put the language bug in my head
so
yeah can i ask which language is
those apr
yeah so currently um
it's
spanish from when i was
incredibly young um then
i started to learn a little bit of
italian and then i pushed it off for a
second and so then i went from there to
danish then picked up italian properly
french
german um
croatian
uh
and russian
i believe i'm that's eight
of course all right so then really only
croatian and danish
sort of correspond to the places where
you played soccer
yeah
more or less uh it's been
you know
yeah
yeah yeah uh those language will
creation and russian as well because i
learned russian in azerbaijan oh in
azerbaijan yeah oh that's interesting so
do they speak more russian there or do
they speak more azeri turk there in
azerbaijan clearly clearly they speak
more azeri turk everyone more or less
does but the
giant majority of even the younger
community and obviously
my teammates
uh some of them
almost i would say 50 spoke excellent
russian the rest basically could
understand and communicate in in russian
and so having gone there with already
knowing a slavic language already having
a good base in croatian serbian right it
was a no-brainer for me to go pick up
russian because i felt that i could use
it in a longer right right right
so i mean obviously
okay i um i presume that english is not
that widespread in or maybe it is in
azerbaijan like how how how
how
no no no you presume correctly so so
obviously if you're in azerbaijan and if
you can speak at least one of the common
languages their life is a lot easier
but how about it oh my god yeah
so that's easy to understand how about
in denmark how useful was it to know
danish in denmark
well the fact that i speak english means
i
don't need to learn danish basically at
all it was on almost
impossible
it was a rarity that i would run into
anyone that could not speak english so
that was a complete choice what happened
was i was at my club and we were full of
foreigners it was almost even 50 percent
foreigners
and
the club director arranged a tutor
for the guys who couldn't speak english
and i went up to him and i said jakub
i want to i want to speak danish and he
just laughed at me because why
why we all speak english you don't need
it i said i want to learn so then the
the tutor had to teach the guys who
didn't speak english english and then
she had to stay after for an hour to
teach me
danish right so that was that was a
decision of mine you know
danish is is the country where they have
a very funny way of counting
from
yeah you know 40 50 60 70 80 is a is a
mouthful
well yeah it's it it's it's crazy
because you go into fm
t
those those ones up to 11 or so are
basically okay but i got thrown off
right of course because
20 because in a two right so you say 1
20. right you know toe to toe and then
yeah but 40.
fair is fair
okay so and how did you learn these
languages
both when you were in the country say
danish and croatian serbian
uh
russian or
you know your other languages like
french and so forth italian uh so yeah
french italian german those ones i could
basically say i stumbled
forwardly like an idiot uh and just
bumbling into that in the very beginning
now that was the very beginning stages
of having no understanding just having a
love for languages and wanting to push
to be there so i literally learned them
by a reading so in college i hated math
uh i now have a greater appreciation for
math but in math class i would have my
italian book out and open in algebra and
i would be studying words and studying
phrases and then i would after i would
go to rye uh go sorry go to the
this we had a back in the day you could
go to the library and watch
tv from all over and so i would go watch
rye and try and pick up some some
languages or
you know in some vocab and so i would
write lists what i found was really
working for me was choosing things
situationally that i could use in order
to immediately then go out and speak the
language so i wouldn't go say study a
list of
what was how to say animals at the zoo
right obviously i would go start and
immediately with the what's uh try and
get myself i enjoy putting myself in
situations that i am not any good at
because i enjoy the fact that it'll
it'll make me better it's just gonna
make you better in speaking so that's
how i bumbled along my way in in italian
to a place where i could finally then
end up going to italy which i went
basically for the first time this past
year and was able to speak and uh with
the languages in the country is
completely different you know because
i've got a a system and a source when
you're in a team
team meetings are in croatian right uh
everything when you go into the taxi all
the games the the referee all this stuff
it's all in croatia so you get a whole
bunch of
listening comprehension right but what i
made sure also to do was i ended up in
croatia i learned
most of my creation from watching
sitcoms and subtitles
i did it that way at the beginning and
then boom i would go and i would just
tell the guys on the field don't talk to
me in english right i would don't right
you know so
yeah that's what did it yeah you know
it's i think work uh you know working or
playing professional sports in a foreign
country is a tremendous way to learn the
language
now maybe it wasn't ideal in denmark
because half of the half your teammates
were foreigners but if you're presumably
in croatia most of your teammates were
croatian so
you're on a team you're you're part of
the team you're part of the group i
think learning languages is so important
to have that sort of sense that you want
to belong to this other culture you want
to be part of them
and so you're not conscious of being
some kind of foreigner learning their
language you just want to be part of
them and and obviously in a team
situation you're playing a game you're
relying on your teammates you're with
your teammates in the dressing room you
go to the you know you'll go out after
for a b or whatever so it's an ideal
language learning scenario
oh totally totally there's nothing
better and that's one of the things is
that i i learned in speaking danish is
that i didn't want to be robbed of a
part of the culture when you learn a
language you get the chance to dive into
it deeper right now one of my favorite
series of all times of all time is
called clone which is a danish comedy
and
there's they don't do it in english they
don't it's not popular in the u.s or you
know in other parts of europe and i
wouldn't have had a
a chance to get to understand the
culture in that way if i didn't choose
to do that right and that also helps you
blend in with the team when they
everybody loves it you know one of the
first things you're going to do when you
get to
a team is they're going to teach you the
swear words and they they think it's
funny when you're on the field if you
just you just say one of the things from
there everybody laughs you know it's
just kind of it's a group of guys that's
just how it is you know on on the
football field and uh but they love it
it's an attempt to connect
what by the way what language did you
use in morocco
french french so i yeah i relied on my
french at that point it was clear my
coach was french uh you know from from
france and everyone it was it was almost
like the complete opposite of azerbaijan
basically all the players clearly spoke
arabic but uh everybody could more or
less get by with
french you could understand and so i
would i'm still going to learn arabic
there's just no way around it it's such
an obvious choice if you're in the
polyglot community it opens up the whole
world to you uh
and i will do it but i am one i'm kind
of and i know you're learning this right
now i'm kind i don't know what to do
because
it's like you've got egyptian arabic the
moroccan it's completely different and
and you don't learn standard arabic i'm
told and
okay i'll give you my experience you'll
make your own choice
but the standard arabic is good because
there's so much material available that
you can access
the distance is not that great levantine
egyptian standard arabic there's kind of
you get to see how they're all part of
the same thing i think the moroccan
algerian is more different so that might
be difficult i i just want to end up by
saying here that you know you have uh
played and therefore worked and lived in
countries that are very different you
know whether it be azerbaijan morocco
you know croatia
uh denmark and to have done that with
the languages which you learned before
or while you were there has given you
you know a perspective on the world the
world of different people which is you
know which is unique it's phenomenal i
salute you for doing it by the way
before we end up here tell us a bit
about your channel and what you're doing
there
oh god so we do everything there you
know so it has its main basis and
obviously
it'd be more interesting probably for
your
viewers to check out the will john
podcast where we're gonna leave a link
in the description box we're gonna leave
yeah yeah yeah but
yeah it's it's uh it's incredible we do
all sorts of things for coaching uh
football funny skits all that stuff it's
just it's wild so you can check that out
too all right will do so yeah i find
this fascinating and my son had that
experience mark you know
we we had two boys we tried to get them
to learn languages because my wife also
speaks four or five languages and of
course they resisted they weren't
interested they wanted nothing to do
with it they just want to play with
their friends
but because mark had the opportunity to
play hockey in italy in switzerland in
austria and then in japan
he realized that hey actually learning
languages is great because okay his
teammates speak these languages
obviously you you connect with the
teammates they're out you know having a
beer after the game whatever it might be
and so i think there's a real connection
between sports and language now not
every athlete gets to travel the world
obviously if you're an american playing
baseball you may not go anywhere but
you might i don't know but uh it can and
i also believe that being physically
active
i think it's good for your brain it's
good for learning in general i think
it's good for learning languages
i've seen some references to studies
that suggest that if you're actually
like if i'm running and listening to my
language which i do that i'm learning
better that there is this connection
between you know whatever you're doing
chemically to your brain by being
physically active has a positive impact
on your ability to learn things
so i would a hundred percent i mean i
know that's something that everybody you
know the the academic worlds and the
sport worlds at times they clash or
they're they're seen as completely
separate but i mean there's no i'm a
huge meditator
and
so i meditate like crazy person and i'm
and what i've noticed is that in
increasing my level of concentration
attention and ability to
be calm not just under stress but just
as a general rule when i'm attempting to
study by doing this i retain more words
uh i find that i don't i get out of my
own way
so i may even i take more calculated
proper risks in the language whereas i
might you know when you and i i
certainly know you do after knowing so
many languages there are many ways to
say a sentence you can protect yourself
quite well in a language by saying the
very basic thing or you can go out on a
limb and start to start a sentence that
you may or may not necessarily know how
to you know completely form and finish
and i found that yeah in working on my
concentration which is nothing
necessarily truly esoteric it's simply
trying to make sure that your mind does
what it's supposed to and not just think
about anything it wants to at any time
you know which is a clear issue you know
with our current society but that's
helped me learn languages more and to
your also to your method of uh listening
and reading
reading cannot
i don't think i would be able to
maintain even the
the small amount of languages that i
know if it wasn't for my ability to be
able to read cyrillic oh yeah and
you know and to read in these languages
in order to really just keep them going
because you get lost in a book you get
lost in these things and they become
you know very strong and it's just
rooted in your brain so i don't know if
you found that but yeah and what i've
because i learned through a lot of
listening and reading that uh if i have
not done anything in the language then i
go back to that language it's like
rediscovering an old friend it's very
comfortable it's a very nice feeling and
and very quickly you come back to where
you were uh one thing i i might be maybe
we're gonna uh we could probably go on
for a long time here could you we i we
started getting into this subject when i
thought we were gonna have to cut off at
12 minutes but can you provide a little
more information about what your podcast
is the kinds of activities
who follows you and so forth and as i
said i'm going to leave a link in the
description box so that people can go
and find you
okay so yeah so i'll explain the whole
entire company like this in in uh
basically uh just a few few sentences
the main channel uh
which is entitled will john which is the
company here i guess you guys can see
the shirts golerami um
it's all about football and learning
football having fun with football
football meaning soccer
football meaning soccer yeah yes yes
and um what i think would be probably
interesting for your for your listeners
obviously those videos if they have
anything in home workouts fitness
nutrition all that stuff so if you're
trying to just get better and more fit
we've got everything you needed there
but uh the podcast has we've had on
naval intelligence officers uh
best-selling
authors uh we've had famous youtubers on
you've had other polyglots you know on
so the
um
the podcast the way of will john we have
one one more called biscuits and c where
we talk about everything
it's there for
literally people like yourself who have
done truly interesting things and are
doing interesting things currently uh
and
the the hope and ideas that in
conversation about you know an hour and
a half two hours sometimes that we can
glean something good
from it and uh that's
that's what we got going on so we film
those and we also have the podcast on
apple and spotify so you can check that
out sounds good okay well we will leave
all the relevant links in the
description box i really enjoyed uh
talking with you we also did one for
your channel
and we have many interests in common uh
my english you know i have a son who
lives in london england my english
grandson is a keen
soccer player and uh liverpool fan and
all that stuff okay uh on this side of
the water where
my grandson's more into hockey but you
know
uh so i envy you your interesting career
and i wish you all the best
and uh thank you for doing this
appreciate it okay
bye bye well
[Music]
you